uh labour's shadow leveling up secretary
and mp for wigan lisa nandy is with us
hi hello good morning thanks for
allowing us to come to this amazing time
um
coverage this week and just chatting to
people
it's been amazing it's brilliant the
whole town is buzzing because you've
been everywhere this week i've been
following your progress beach hill
primary school the
brick all over the town and seeing the
amazing stuff that people are doing here
even in really difficult times even with
the government that is standing aside
while people are in crisis we're
stepping up and getting on with it
that's what as you know this town has
always done people are doing it right
across the country but this week in
parliament the government had a chance
to actually back their people didn't do
it and i've just got back from london
just got home and i'm pretty cross about
it
well you say that but you know the
government would say in response to that
we are heading towards a recession
they're doing absolutely everything they
can it looks as though we will see a tax
decrease probably in the summer there
isn't a magic money tree they can only
do so much
some of the measures that we proposed
yesterday in parliament that the
government voted down don't actually
cost the public any money we called for
a windfall tax on the oil and gas
producers they made record profits it's
only 600 quid a household even if it
goes through but you know that every
single pound that goes into people's
pockets at the moment can be the
difference between make or break most
people now are struggling to keep their
heads above water we also ask them to to
cancel their planned national insurance
contributions rise
we had a lot of money coming into the
into the coffers we are the only
developed country that's putting up
taxes on working people in the middle of
not just an inflation crisis but also
coming out the other side of a global
pandemic and you've heard it all week
you've heard it from people in every
part of this town not just people who
were struggling before but people who've
never struggled before and are now just
finding that they don't know how they're
going to pay their rent their mortgage
they don't know how they're going to
afford their weekly shop as well as
their energy bill and the government
should be doing every single thing that
they can moving heaven and earth to try
and help people at the moment well the
national insurance increase is bringing
in a lot of money so they would say of
course that's what we need to do at the
moment a windfall tax would only bring
in about two billion pounds it's just a
drop in the bucket so what would labour
do well as as well as those two things
the other thing that we proposed
yesterday was cracking on with
retrofitting homes putting home
insulation into people's homes well
that's been an ongoing program that has
fallen off a cliff under this government
but the councils are raring to go to to
to do it's an investment k this is the
point what was it
but it would it would cut 400 pounds of
people's energy bills and you know that
if you get every year and if you get
money back into working people's pockets
they go out and spend it when you walk
up and down the high street you must see
that although we're still doing okay
here in wigan you've got money lenders
boarded up shops at the bottom of the
high street we didn't have those 10
years ago and that's because we
prioritized putting money into people's
pockets so they could go out and spend
it it's nonsense to talk about leveling
up this country as the government used
to do but seems to have abandoned when
you're not putting money into working
people's pockets where's the investment
going to come from to to make people's
homes less drafty et cetera where's that
money coming from well look it's an
investment
first few measures that we proposed are
cost neutral to the public purse the
third one
is about potentially bringing forward
benefit operating so you calculate the
amount that benefits increase every year
based on inflation the current benefit
system is based on in the inflation rate
last year which was dramatically lower
so one thing that the government could
do that wouldn't cost any money is bring
that forward and we asked them to look
at that as well yesterday every single
one of those measures the chancellor set
his face against and said not now but
now is the moment when this money and
this help really counts for people we
need a government that backs our people
we're doing great work as you can see
but we need a government that steps up
and helps us now you say that the
government is not in charge but some of
the people i've been talking to this
week have talked about that posh bloke
who's been knighted with a really nice
suit on who comes from a really posh
part of london you know how much is he
in touch with what's happening here i
think he's very in touch he and i are
going to be in leeds in just a few hours
time talking to people about the cost of
living crisis we've been all over the
country to grimsby to burnley to
doncaster in recent months listening to
what people have got to say which is why
we came forward with this package of
emergency measures in the budget this
week in the in the queen's speech this
week to try to get the government to
bring forward an emergency budget i
think people do appreciate actually that
kierstama is trying to make sure that
the main concern for most people is
heard and dealt with at the highest
levels of government if he were prime
minister right now people would not be
struggling to survive and put food on
the table because we would be knocking
600 pounds off energy bills for those
who most need it 200 pounds for
everybody and bringing forward an
emergency budget to actually start to
tackle this problem what is it about the
posh borough of islington and labour
leaders though you know we've had four
or five only one of them has been
successful
well look throughout our history labour
has had to fight really hard to gain the
public's trust and inspire people to
vote for us we've only won three times
in our entire history i'm determining
that the next time is going to be at the
next election and i'll tell you why
because i wake up every single day in my
town looking around me thinking imagine
what we could do with the government
that backed us we've survived really
tough times here in wigan you know that
when the mines closed it was really
difficult a decade of austerity has not
been kind to us wigan council has had
the third worst budget cuts in the
country but despite all of that look at
the spirit here look at what we're doing
and imagine what we could do with the
government that backed us take questions
before i let you go i know you need to
go to lee's the sun's saying this
morning that labour might not might get
as many as 20 police questionnaires over
beer gates it's just bad as downstream
well look we've already been cleared for
this once and i'm confident that we'll
be cleared again i'm not surprised that
the tories are trying to throw mud at us
i think it suits them to talk about that
when they don't want to talk about
what's actually happening to people in
places like wigan and we're determined
that that's not going to happen right up
and down this country at the moment
people are in crisis people are in pain
and we're going to do something to sort
that out
why do you think the toys have not
withdrawn the work from an mp that's
been accused of rape i don't know but i
share the view of many conservative
female mps who've spoken out in the last
few hours about that over the last 24
hours since this news came into the
public domain i just think this is
disgraceful parliament is supposed to be
not just a safe place to work not just
for mps but for all of the staff who
work there but also we're supposed to
set an example to the rest of the
country and i just genuinely cannot
understand that decision i want to give
those brave conservative mps who've
spoken out about the decision by their
own wits my absolute full backing today
something has got to be done 50 odd mps
including from your own front bench
being investigated i mean is it not a
safe space for women in the chamber i
mean look i don't think parliament is a
particularly modern workplace i would
love us to move out of the building it's
sinking into the mud it's riddled with
asbestos it needs serious work i'd love
us to turn that building into a place
that people could come and look around a
museum something to learn about the
history of parliamentary democracy and
go and work in a modern workplace where
people have normal decent professional
standards most people who work there are
decent they are professional but there's
still far too much of an old boys club
about it it means that people like me
when you walk in there for the first
time
is disgraceful but i also think it's
cultural i think there's some kind of
feeling of entitlement amongst some of
the members of parliament not not many i
have to say most of us are quite normal
people but there is this feeling of
arrogance of entitlement this culture
that has grown up that i think we've got
to
consign to the bin of history this is
2022 and we cannot continue with a
situation where a small minority of
people are able to go and walk around
behaving like this at the heart of our
democracy i must let you please it's
good to talk to you thanks very much